Our final suspect, Smash Mouth.
Yes, the '90s alternative
rocker's responsible for a
musical genre we now refer to as
Shrek-core, has been a constant
target since our show's
inception.
Now, we are not 100% sure if
Smash Mouth has the
technology...
(beeping)
What?
(static and beeping)
>> Hey, now.
This is me, Mr. Steve Harwell,
lead singer of the
multi-platinum, GRAMMY-nominated
band, Smash Mouth.
I just heard that somebody was
talking shit about my band.
And his name is Chris Hardwick,
A.K.A. Dollar Store Ryan
Seacrest, okay?
I'm sorry for you dicking around
with my band.
That's not cool, brother, okay?
We got to stop that kind of
stuff.
We may not be for everyone,
and I admit that.
But we make perfect music for
many situations:
Like a super chill divorce
hearing, a raging Bat Mitzvah,
or a beautiful chili-cheese orgy
with Guy Fieri, one of my great
friends.
Now, I'm not saying I hacked
into your guys computer using
high-tech powered flip-flops and
hair product, but if I did,
listen up.
All you comedians out there, I
command you tweet a nice thing
about my band right now.
And if you don't, I'm gonna tell
you one last thing:
This ain't no joke.
(static)
>> HARDWICK: Wow.
(cheering and applause)
That was very serious.
We got to give it to him.
We've got to have a huge hand
for Steve Harwell for, uh,
taking our abuse.
(cheering and applause)
I give him points.
Maybe I got Smash Mouth on my
iPhone sometimes, you guys.